all set for game two of this series
after the red sox took the opener last
night 5-3
78 degrees a little bit humid but
the packed house at fenway park
incredible environment last night
vivaldi coming off his shortest outing
of the year sunday in kansas city four
runs over four innings but overall
pretty darn good here in his fourth
season with the red sox
acquired at the deadline from tampa bay
in 2018 was a huge part of their world
series run inside a contract following
that year there's a ground ball into
center field for a lead-off hit for d.j
lemayhew promptly extending his hitting
streak to nine games
he shoots one on the ground his second
here chavis to bogarts easy turn to
first a double play
four six three to wipe them clean two
gone here in the first hits it over to
second base
again a man that big he's just gonna
have to try to pound in with hard stuff
and ivaldi has the ability to do that
throwing close to 100 miles an hour
two balls and two strikes vivaldi comes
home and sanchez pokes one to right base
hit
second opposite field here to the inning
for the yankees
sanchez keeps the ending going that just
a great job of hitting right there
because that's it that's an excellent
pitch i mean that's a fastball that's
even maybe off the plate a little bit
you know sanchez maybe a month and a
half ago he's swinging trying to take
that thing deep and probably missing it
there's some debris blowing across the
field toward right breaking ball swung
on and missed for strike three vivaldi
gives up two hits that gets the
strikeout of stanton jordan montgomery
who made his debut in 2017 pitched that
full season pretty much in the majors
but then missed almost two full years
following tommy john struggled last year
he's been getting better and better
though uk the yankees are 11-3 in his 14
starts yeah he he's a pitcher and what i
mean by that he's not just going to try
and overpower somebody
you see that he throws his change up and
sinker i mean those two pitches are
relatively equivalent as far as usage
we'll go to the curve ball
forcing fastball occasionally
but the change up for me that's you're
gonna see that a lot tonight let's a
one-two fly and chavis hits a bouncing
ball to short sliding play torres pops
to his feet and a low throw dug out by
voight
chavis the first out well torrez isn't
really known as being a slick fielding
shortstop but that play right there very
nice
taps this one gently right side
montgomery there with the backhand flips
it with a glove to get verdugo two up
two down in this first inning jordan
montgomery looking for one two three
first he's got it cutting one under the
swing of martinez no score after one now
two weight there's blade retores torres
absolutely cannot buy a hit little
number on the left side charged by
devers bare hands and throws him out
beautiful play he had to go a long way
to his left with bogart's charging right
behind him but debra stepped in front of
him picked it off the ground bare hand
and made a beautiful throw and the count
is full again with runners at first and
second and nobody out red sox trying to
take the lead here in the second in the
score this game payoff pitch the
runner's not going a smash that hits
montgomery off the leg carrups toward
third base everybody's going to be safe
montgomery limped a little bit toward
the third baseman or shella to go field
it but he seems to be okay
second infield single of the inning and
the red sox have loaded the bases with
nobody out base is loaded in the second
hernandez
swings at the first one sends it in the
air to center field
gardner back to catch it but plenty deep
enough to bring home bogarts for the
first run of the game hernandez with an
rbi sac fly and it's one nothing boston
one out still have an opportunity for
another sacrifice flight paused by
jordan montgomery the lefty deal
swinging a pop fly
wide of first voight running out of room
as he goes after the foul ball and makes
the catch here comes devers tagging and
he will score what a heads-up play
raphael devers tags up and scores on a
pop-up in foul ground that was probably
only about 40 feet past the first base
bag
luke voight took a very strange route to
that almost made a complete circle
around it he dropped one last night so
he had his back to the plate when he
made the catch and he turned around took
several steps i think he was very
surprised to see devers charging down
the line now a chance to do damage again
they shift bringing feelers on the left
side
he punches one off the end of the bat
defense was shifted around not an easy
play and he's a board with an infield
hit it's three-nothing red sox as the
paper cuts to montgomery continue
trouble getting a grip perhaps and it's
three-nothing red sox has never scores
or the infield hits keep on coming this
is unreal what jordan montgomery should
do right here right
four out of the six hits have been
infield hits
the 1-2 pitch
dalbeck
drops it to center gardner going back to
the track with just enough room to make
the catch
and end the ending
field swim around toward right for
urchela renfro plays a shallow right
field that's hit toward left toward the
gap but racing over and making a sliding
catch is alex ferdugo it's a good thing
he was swung around toward right because
that ball was well into the left center
field gap but well positioned now the
3-2 pitch swinging a well-hit ball
center field kk hernandez retreating
he's back to the wall in center and
makes the catch right up against the
padding long fly ball out by torres to
the right of the 379 marker breeze
blowing out then that might have helped
take it all the way to the wall you kind
of feel like this game you know watching
it up to this point it just seems like
the red sox are winning 15 to nothing
right and yet here we are one swing of
the bat we could have a tie ball game
here's the pitch swing ground ball hit
the third good hop for devers to second
out on to first pick by dead dog double
play what a
outstanding stab on a one hop throw from
chavis the double play ends the inning
outstanding play taylor made double play
ball chavis had a one-hopped feed to the
right field side of the bag and dalbeck
snapped it there's two starts this
season against the yankees one earned
run over 11 innings beat him in early
june trying to do the same here
in game two of this three-game series at
fenway
off the end of the bat at second chavis
will shovel it on to second one
not in time at first board to keep the
inning going torres two for his last 41.
this is a guy who had over 30 home runs
herschela takes off it's a fastball
ripped to left center field running
catch by [ __ ] hernandez
nate avaldi's seven shutout innings and
a three nothing lead for the red sox as
we stretch chavis at third martinez is
second
one oh to bogarts
is lifted to left center field coming on
gardner dives
and makes the catch
chavis comes in to score four nothing
boston wasn't it very high was it very
hard so the red sox have three sac flies
tonight first time this season he's
throwing a pitch in the eighth inning
he's crossed 100 four times with a
season high of 107. dominant tonight 5ks
no walks
swinging a miss a fastball at 98 miles
an hour on the 102nd pitch of the night
from nathan avaldi who is now struck out
six and to the top of the order and here
is le mayhew and the pitch is hit in the
ears of breaking ball the deep right
center and that ball is gone into the
bullpen so dj lemayo takes a breaking
ball and hits it the opposite way where
most of his home runs go that will end
his night he'll still get a great hand
from this packed house at fenway park
leaving with a 4-1 lead
against his old teammate adam adevino
having a great first season in boston
bases loaded in the eighth luke voight
pulls one left side
at short bogarts
boston out of the bases loaded jam that
was more harrowing than it needed to be
just the one run on the homer by le
mayhew for the second time in the last
two innings the yankees getting the
tying run to the plate payoff pitch
lemay who goes up the middle with a base
hit into center field
and to score
the tying run reaches
the go ahead run comes up in the form of
aaron judge
he struck him out
of hino's labor to dig deep to slam the
door
boston wins it 4-2